today we're talking about zero trust vpc
service controls and a podcast about the
blog
i am priyanka and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
we believe zero trust is an effective
way to enhance overall security and
provide a better user experience and
beyond corp enterprise can help make
this possible
that's why we're excited to announce
three new beyond core enterprise
features designed to help our customers
provide their users simple and secure
access to key applications certificate
based access via vpc service controls
on-prem connector and easy to configure
custom access policies
google cloud strives to be the most
trusted cloud which is why we are
continuously updating our protection
capabilities in addition to iap we now
support vpc service controls for cloud
run which creates enterprise-grade
security guard rails protecting your
data at the network level while
delivering the ease of use and speed to
market
the google cloud tech blog is a great
resource for all things happening in
google cloud and if you prefer to listen
rather than read check out the google
cloud reader podcast available wherever
you listen to podcasts and enjoy an
audio version of the latest and greatest
with google cloud if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you